vous voyez des images de voyageurs
soulagés qui sont rentrés hier à
l'aéroport pierre-elliot-trudeau en
provenance d'haïti où ils sont restés
coincés pendant des jours dans leur
hôtel de pays vous le savez qui est
empreint de flambée de violence avec
plusieurs manifestations avec moi
christophe est hennebelle porte parole
d'air transat
bonjour messieurs bonjour khartoum on
est rentrés sains et saufs
tout le monde est entré en collision
temps est absolument qu'il ait la
complexité d'une opération de
rapatriement comme celle là alors la
complexité c'était surtout la partie
terrestre en fait donc c'était d'amener
les voyageurs à l'aéroport puisqu'on
n'avait pas de problème avec les avions
dans n'a pas eu pendant toute cette
semaine là on a dû orchestrer un
véritable ballet d'hélicoptères avec
quatre appareils
oui c'est ça on assister à ça d'ailleurs
en direct hier matin pourtant il ya
certaines de vos compétiteurs qu'ils
avaient fait plusieurs jours avant vous
pourquoi avoir attendu autant alors je
suis pas sûr qu'on ait vraiment des
compétiteurs qui est orchestré sans nom
n'a pas trouvé trace en tout cas
certains voyageurs étaient rentrés par
eux mêmes en hélicoptère mais c'était
pas pour nous la solution la plus sécure
donc on était vraiment concentré sur une
solution terrestre par un convoi de bus
protéger et c'est seulement quand cette
solution s'est avéré absolument
impraticable
conte et passer au plan b avait dit un
touriste à qu'il y avait des compagnies
aériennes étaient venus chercher
certains 2d de voyageurs dans leurs
hôtels avec un dictateur je crois pas
que ce soit exact on sait que américaine
ne l'a pas fait par exemple ils nous
l'ont confirmée ni une compagnie
canadienne
d'accord il ya des agents de l'hôtel
hier matin qui disait pourquoi air
transat ne pas tout simplement annulé
notre départ notre forfait voyage avant
de partir c'est toujours plus facile
évidemment en regardant après coup mais
à ce moment là au moment où les
voyageurs sont partis on n'avait pas
encore d'indication forte qui avait un
danger
donc on continuer à exploiter et puis
malheureusement la situation s'est
dégradée très rapidement ensuite c'était
à quelle date la dernière fois où vous
avez amené des gens pour pour un forfait
ans
alors la dernière fois pour un forfait
c'était dimanche dernier dimanche de la
semaine dernière ont continué à
exploiter aujourd'hui des vols réguliers
dans quelques jours après le début des
manifestations les manies de les choses
se sont véritablement gâtés à partir de
dimanche lundi
d'accord donc à son malheur vous avez
décidé de regarder la situation
d'attendre pour voir si la voiture est
salée pouvoir être empruntés et par la
suite organisé ce ballet d'hélicoptères
comme pleinement et absolument à ce
ballet c'était de la complexité de la
complexité c'est du risque évidemment et
nous s'il ya une chose qu'on aime pas
pour nos clients c'est le risque
donc on était concentré sur la voie
terrestre temps qu'elle paraissait
possible
ensuite on est passé aux hélicoptères
est ce qu'il y aura un dédommagement
quelconque pour les gens qui avaient
payé pour une semaine de vacances ici on
est dans un cas de force majeure donc on
a évidemment payé pour nos clients qui
sont restés plus longtemps que ce qu'ils
auraient dû
c'est nous qui avons pris ça en charge
on a pris en charge également toute
l'opération de rapatriement et s'il ya
des nuitées qui n'avait pas été qui
n'ont pas pu être consommée c'est à dire
des gens qui sont rentrés plus tôt
ces nuitées là seront remboursés
d'accord est-ce que vous continuez à
opérer vols réguliers présentant
absolument oui d'accord parce qu'air
canada a décidé d'annuler certains vols
et en vol de demain mais pour les autres
jours c'est un délai vous vous prendrez
pourquoi air canada a arrêté
effectivement nous nous continuerons
d'abord parce qu'il ya des gens qui
veulent encore rentré d'haïti donc tant
qu'on peut le faire on va continuer à le
faire il ya aussi des haïtiens qui
veulent rentrer au pays
donc tant que ça paraîtra praticable et
pas dangereux
on continuera à exploiter d'ailleurs on
a reçu ce matin le journaliste est
d'origine haïtienne qui part ce matin
avec un vol le diable rouge est à 10
heures
ce matin mais sinon pour les autres
personnes qui sont là bas et qui
voudraient revenir ya pas de
d'opérations quelconque l'a prévu pour
les amenèrent par des parts au prix a
pas d'opérations terrestres non
continuer les opérations aériennes donc
il faut qu'ils se rendent à l'aéroport
pour pouvoir prendre l'avion absolue est
ce que vous craignez que ça a un impact
sur l'industrie touristique vous
construisez depuis quelques années des
gens knight mais j'espère que ça ne sera
pas trop d'impact pour haïti parce
qu'évidemment nos pensées vont aussi aux
haïtiens maintenant le le tourisme est
un facteur important de l'économie en
haïti donc on espère que les choses vont
pouvoir se rétablir et qu'on va pouvoir
continuer à travailler avec nos amis
haïtiens pour aider à bâtir leur
économie et quand vous faites votre post
mortem sk des erreurs que vous ne
referiez pas est ce qu'il ya des leçons
vous tiré de ce que vous vivez
je crois que c'est une opération qui a
été bien maîtrisée évidemment on sachant
ce que je sais aujourd'hui en sachant
que la voie terrestre était impraticable
au final on aurait peut-être mis en
place les hélicoptères plus tôt mais au
moment où on faisait les choses c'était
difficile de le savoir
ça fait une belle porte parole d'air
transat merci merci ce matin merci bien
lorsqu'on voit